what up guys
good morning
um it's that morning coffee thoughts
morning smoothie because i'm
i'm changing today is day one of
quitting coffee
i'm so good at smoothies um okay
so today
i want to talk about
when people leave
and when people
you know like
okay
there have been times where people have
left my life and i was so sad and i i
was like
depressed like so sad that they laughed
but every single time somebody has left
like
someone else has come in the picture to
take their place and it has worked out
better for me and they
were typically a better friend or better
you know
boyfriend or
something like whenever
i'll give you an example okay last year
got out of this relationship that was
just we were bad for each other okay i'm
not i'm not perfect it just it wasn't
good right
and i was so sad
i was fat
i had a little fat on vacation i'm not
gonna lie i'm going to the gym today to
work it off
um
but i had oh my god my skin was so
broken out i was so stressed out
and you guys saw me in my videos like if
you look at my videos from like six
months a year ago like i was you could
just tell mentally i was like
not
in a good place
and literally the second i left that
relationship i started a show
my youtube channel took off my skin
cleared
my
i got a new group of friends
that i mean i wouldn't say group i don't
have that many friends
i don't i wouldn't say and i had a
couple friends leave because of what i
do
but every single time like
at someone that i get along with better
and causes me less of a headache comes
in
so
i don't know like
i i used to be really afraid of people
leaving like that was like my biggest
fear was i just hated the thought of
like people that i love leaving and not
being in my life anymore like
this
and it's still to this day i mean my
parents my family like that that scares
me right but
every time someone has left like it has
always turned out to be a blessing in
disguise like without fail hold on i'm
gonna get a water hold on
no
okay hold on hold on
um
my voice is starting to crash oh god oh
god oh god okay i live in a studio
like if i was too afraid of my
ex-boyfriend leaving or like afraid that
that would end
i
i would still be stuck in a shitty
relationship and my point is
i think a lot of times in our 20s we
cling on to things that are done and i
see men do this all the time they're
with a shitty woman
and
they cling on to it because they love
her and they don't want to see her leave
and they don't
like the idea of her not being in their
life but they know that that woman is
isn't the one for you
and i felt that way too but the longer
like i just
life is so short it is like i'm 25 and i
know i have a lot of my life ahead of me
but i think about how if i live to be 75
a third of my life is done
and
i don't ever want to look back and think
that i didn't do something that i wanted
to do
like everything i want to do i'm trying
to build i wanted to have a show i built
a show i wanted to
i want
we were talking about some ideas
yesterday about doing like a reality tv
youtube show
oh my god i can make it so funny i'm
bringing people from like the man of
sphere i would make it so funny um
but
like every i just want to try to do
everything i want to do even if it's not
on like international skills just like
in my town
and if you're stuck investing in shitty
relationships that don't benefit you
like you it is so distracting like one i
think your body knows because my body i
swear to god was so broken out and just
like
inflamed when i was in that relationship
and
like
i i don't know i think your body just
like knows and that you put time and
energy into something that's not serving
you
so
i don't know this is this is your sign
if you're in a shitty relationship to
leave it
and if you're with a good woman to work
it out because good people are and this
is something the manuscript doesn't talk
about good people are hard to find and
when you do find good people you should
work it out with them
because
trust me
yeah good good people are tough to find
and if you find them work it out so
those are my morning smoothie thoughts
um don't forget to subscribe like the
video for real subscribe like half of
you don't even subscribe to my videos
which is nonsense nonsense okay
i'll talk to you guys next time